you got married since the last time I  say congratulations been two years you  know what is the secret in your opinion  to a happy relationship well we don't  know so we went to go see a relationship  coach of the Guttman's there's a Seattle  there an older Jewish couple and the  Gatlin that Gottman's  okay and they teach you the Four  Horsemen of the Apocalypse and  relationship which are criticism  contempt defensiveness and stonewalling  so if your partner said something like  oh look at that sailboat criticism  that's a stupid sailboat  contempt you were good sailboat who says  that about sailboats  here you can sailboat  and then you try to you know say  something nice like oh sailboat you you  have such a wonderful high from the Sun  I'm like I'm always delighted by that  one about what you see no they were  talking to him like he had his head on a  rock  you